bonjour et merci d'être sur rt france ce
matin bonjour qui motive votre décision
de ne pas faire contrôler le pass
sanitaire par les policiers municipaux
en terrasse écoutez nous sommes en
pleine saison touristique les acteurs
économiques ont pâti d'une crise
économique et sanitaire sans précédent
aujourd'hui les choses se relance en
profitent de la saison et voilà qu'on
interdit à une partie de la population
d'aller sur les terrasses de nos
restaurateurs et de nos bars cette
situation n'est pas acceptable cela
consignes à de la vaccination
obligatoire deux sets je m'y oppose je
ne souhaite pas que la police municipale
de fréjus participent à ce flicage
généralisé en réalité ce monde en tout
cas super ou dans lequel tous on va être
vont être surveillés par des policiers
par des gérants de restaurants tout cela
n'est pas acceptable il n'y a eu aucune
concertation avec les élus locaux sur ce
point du contrôle l'epa sanitaires non
peu de concertation et d'ailleurs s'il y
avait eu concertation la plupart des
maires auraient dit que par exemple il
fallait faire l'impasse sur le pass
sanitaire en terrasse nous voulons bien
organisé le pas salutaire dans les très
grands événements avec plusieurs
milliers de personnes pourquoi pas
l'intérieur on peut encore en discuter
je n'y suis pas opposé mais sur les
terrasses à l'extérieur cela n'a
absolument aucun sens d'ailleurs sur la
plage où il ya des milliers de personnes
il y anime as tu me passes sanitaires on
n'a pas noté de clusters majeur donc je
crois que le gouvernement dans cette
affaire est excessif et qu'il faut qu'il
revienne à la raison alors selon la
récente loi sur la sécurité globale le
maire a pleine et entière compétences
sur les missions de ces agents
municipaux mais si on se réfère au code
général des collectivités territoriales
toute décision ce sens se fait sous le
contrôle administratif du préfet que
vous dit le préfet aujourd'hui
il s'exprime dans les médias pour
expliquer que je c'est un coup politique
qui croit qu il manque ainsi d'ailleurs
à son devoir de réserve je crois que
dans notre constitution pour parler du
fond il ya la libre administration des
collectivités territoriales
c'est important la police municipale
elle prend ses ordres et là des
priorités qui viennent de la
municipalité est ma priorité et les
clairs c'est la lutte contre la
délinquance contre les vols contre 1
pour l'ordre public de manière générale
et certainement pas ce flicage qui
m'apparaît en même temps déraisonnable
et un peu grotesque le plan sanitaire
encore une fois puisque les deux choses
l'une soit les personnes qui sont
vaccinées sont protégés et alors on ne
voit pas ce qu'elles craignent sur les
terrasses soit elles ne le sont pas et
alors je m'interroge la préfecture du
var qui dénoncent elles vous l'avez
évoqué une manoeuvre politicienne de
votre part vous lui répondez quoi
précisément aujourd'hui écoutez je je je
pense que ça n'est pas sérieux de la
part d'un préfet de faire des
commentaires politiques simplement je
note que pour ce qui est des services de
l'état lorsqu'on n'est pas totalement
d'accord avec la doxa du gouvernement
totalement d'accord avec les mesures du
gouvernement totalement d'accord avec la
vaccination obligatoire qui sont en
train de faire de mettre en oeuvre alors
on est qualifié de manoeuvre il est
politique je encore une fois je m'en
étonne mais de finalement ça n'est pas
très important l'essentiel c'est ce que
pensent les habitants de territoire et
qu'en est-il aussi alors de
l'application du ps sanitaire dans le
reste de votre ville au delà des
terrasses mais il n'y a pas de
difficultés majeures les gestes
barrières sont respectées le port du
masque quand il est demandé est
respectée lorsque nous faisons des
grandes manifestations plusieurs
milliers de personnes
le pack sanitaire est d'ailleurs bien
compris donc pas de problème en réalité
simplement encore une fois des éléments
de la vie si basique que de prendre un
café que d'aller au restaurant en pleine
période estivale dans le sud de la
france
eh bien ces mesures ne correspondent pas
à la réalité des choses à l'arrêté de ce
qu'il faudrait faire encore une fois on
ne on n'attrape pas cette maladie à
l'extérieur on attrape passe maladie en
terrasse ou en tout cas de manière très
faibles donc une nouvelle fois il faut
que le gouvernement revienne à la raison
et assouplissent les choses d'autant que
je le rappelle dans le var le taux
d'incidence est sur un plateau il
n'augmente plus donc ces mesures ne sont
pas nécessaires merci beaucoup d'avoir
réagi sur notre antenne david rachline
la rn2 fréjus